sometimes I need to really choose what
are the dreams that I want to pursue
it's a constant evaluation and you have
to be willing to let go of the good to
go for the great if the overwhelm is I
don't know how I'm gonna make this thing
then default to just immediate action
because your how is not going to work
out anyway like how you think you're
going to accomplish your goal right now
is not how it's actually going to be so
don't waste time thinking about how it's
all going to work out just start doing
it and the plan will will be created as
you go like you can only really plan one
or two steps out not all the way we're
so worried about where we're going that
we haven't taken the time to look back
and say oh I was over there that's crazy
which helps with the overwhelm as well
it helps with the Imposter syndrome it
helps with the I'm not good enough you
think well I'm not Oprah or I'm not
whoever you know whoever your hero is
I'm not I'm not that big yet you know
when do I start sharing but like you've
already you've already had an impact
you're already doing it
what's your process to always keep
believing in yourself what a start this
is great step one is just it's more
action you know like if you're
overthinking and you're stuck in in not
believing in yourself it you just go off
and do it like that idea that you've got
I expect it to suck I mean we talk about
it in in you know momentum like I
expected something brand new I expected
this I expect me to suck at doing that
thing I expect no results to come I just
expect it to suck and I I just love
pushing through on momentum
um default to action more action you get
an idea like how much can you do while
you're in that zone like I wrote that
book in five days when I had no time to
write a book
um I just came back from speaking in
Arizona and San Diego and arrived on
what arrived two days ago and I was
living with Nick who's who's on our team
doing a lot of the marketing stuff and
okay what are we going to do with like
now right here while we're here like not
when we get home not next week not when
we've got more times like what what are
we doing right now we met up into
Starbucks in the morning and and mapped
the whole thing out
so whatever the thing is that you're
struggling with or the ideas that you
come up with it's like what what is the
Massive Action you can just default to
doing right now more like create more
because inside of the Massive Action
maybe not everything works out but
there's a seed of something and one
thing starts to to lift off I don't
beside the IG live I did with uh with
kale a couple days ago but awesome uh
young 17 year old uh guy who wants to
become a singer like okay cool 30-day
challenge I want you to make a new song
every day for 30 days do do uh like five
covers and then an original song uh and
I basically at the point for what it
should be doing every day and and he's
been doing it he's on day five or six
right now through the challenge right
and not all the songs have taken out but
one of them has 800 or 900 views now
which for him is huge because he's he's
just getting started it's like wow I got
800 900 reviews on one video
this is where most people will fall
apart is that the video that got the 800
900 views for him was not his first one
it was like the third or fourth one
and we tend to put so much expectations
on that first thing working out as
opposed to say I'm just gonna I'm gonna
make Massive Action and one of these
things will pan out
so whatever the thing is on your list
you go and you make and you create and
like when you're in action mode you're
not in overthinking mode
because you're doing
so especially at the beginning
so is there like is there an idea that
you want to work on like why did why
this question sometimes I need to to to
Really choose what are the dreams that I
want to pursue because I'm always you
know thinking on stuff the first thing
is my job it's always my you know my
family my job because my job is what I
love to do and also what you know allows
me to to maintain my family so that's a
big thing and um and it also it is all
connected to my passion which is working
with immigrants so I'm doing that I'm
also working on my YouTube channel and
uh and and
um there's also a salsa a salsa group
that
I'm also working on that like so we can
learn to to lead and to follow at both
at the same time
um and uh my project with women so those
are kind of the main things it's uh
except with the salsa uh group it's all
connected to the Immigrant world and
today to
um to the to the to my work somehow and
what happens sometimes and I don't
normally see that with me but many many
times with my clients is that um there
are many
many times when you feel that your
circumstances start to be like too big
or you know like there's no
sometimes it's like you feel that there
there's not enough you to do all the
things that you want
so you start feeling a little bit
um frustrated in the sense that okay I'm
not being able to do as much as I want
I'm doing it but maybe I'm going too
slowly or maybe I'm not uh doing as good
as I wish I can do stuff and for at
least for me one of my biggest things is
big I don't want to disappoint those
that I care about
so you know I try to deliver in whatever
I get I try to deliver but sometimes
it's like because of the circumstances
again you know uh the you know the the
time constraints and many
responsibilities the the nature of the
demands I have sometimes I feel like a
little bit overwhelmed and uh start
feeling like okay so am I enough to do
all these dreams that I have and just
today I was talking to a client in the
morning and he was having the same thing
the same feelings like okay I'm here now
I'm in this country it's great but now
I'm feeling that I'm just I'm just not
being able to go to the places or do the
things that I wanted because I don't
know if I'm you know how I'm gonna deal
with everything so that's kind of like
the process I'm trying to to extract
from you how do you organize you know
how how do you manage to
being able to deal and go beyond your
circumstances so I don't um
I would I would put personally I'll put
them in two different categories right
circumstances versus feeling overwhelmed
and the circumstances it's recognizing
that people with weight less than you
have done way more like be around your
Heroes more who have you looked up to
look at what they've done you have no
reason why you can't do it too and so I
surround myself with my heroes through
the videos that I mostly videos
um sometimes books or shows but like the
videos themselves if I see Oprah and
what she went through of
look she's a great reminder for me of
she was sexually abused and didn't have
great parents and grew up most with her
grandmother and uh
was so poor that she had to go to school
in a potato sack like her grandmother
couldn't afford so you know like imagine
going to school in a potato bag
and you think you have problems right
and then she became Oprah so
what's your excuse right this is what I
would tell myself was like well we're
now in 2022 going into 2023. the
resources that you have you have the
internet like you have so much more
opportunity than even your parents had
at your age and so
it's just perspective and looking out
and looking at whoever your heroes are
they started with less than what you
have right now
and so it's not an issue of circumstance
it's deciding that it's not an issue of
circumstance right so that one doesn't
usually get me tripped up too much for
overwhelm
uh
I'll go through phases of
I get an idea
immediate action I don't stress out
about like I think you get overwhelmed
because you have to figure out all of
the is either you have to figure out the
whole plan
like I want to start this thing I don't
know how to how to do it we focus so
much on the how of this big idea that
then it blocks us from creating
and so instead of focusing on the on the
fully mapped out how I'll focus on what
I have to do right now
at the at the event that I just came
back from I I came up with some ideas of
these new shows that I wanted to start I
want to start a new Regular Show uh for
the Gaming Community for the nft
community
um for the entrepreneur community and
what was the last ones there's four
shows that I want to start and I get
inspired while I'm in the middle of
somebody's talk
so for the next
I don't know two hours all I'm all I'm
doing is is messaging people who I think
might be a good fit for the show like
I'm not paying attention anymore to the
speaker I'm not worried about anything
else going on and I'm just okay I need
to get this show up what does it look
like what technology we're going to use
there's gonna be Zoom or something now I
don't know I like don't work because you
can't map out the whole plan
it's just getting started what's the
first step I need I need to find
somebody to do the show with me so
that's my next step and then that day I
met somebody uh in my nft community at a
at a cafe to talk about it that night I
got on a zoom call with someone in
Gaming Community to talk about it and I
met with somebody at the event to talk
in the entrepreneurial Community about
doing something together it's like
immediate action on the thing
I would have taken that could have taken
months or years or some people to think
through like who's gonna be the perfect
fit and on and what did they say no what
if they don't like me and what if I'm
not good enough and what like all the
what ifs get solved by just doing stuff
I know right so just creating
the second part so that's like the first
if the overwhelm is I don't know how I'm
gonna make this thing then default to
just immediate action because your how
is not going to work out anyway like the
how you think you're going to accomplish
your goal right now is not how it's
actually going to be so so don't waste
time thinking about how it's all going
to work out just start doing it and the
plan will will be created as you go like
you can only really plan one or two
steps out not all the way so the
overwhelm is coming from
how am I going to reach the goal then
that's not a good use of any mental
energy and default to just more
immediate action if the overwhelm is I'm
doing too many things
then it's cutting down some of the
things
maybe maybe the salsa group's not the
thing you want to do anymore I don't
know but maybe right so it's like when I
went away on my trip
uh I came back and I stopped the the
gaming channel
so I don't know if you've ever joined
our gaming channel but I was I was
gaming four days a week at night to
answer questions and I haven't I told
you and I haven't I haven't gone live on
my gaming channel since
because when it was away
I didn't miss it
I didn't even feel overwhelm it's not
like oh my God I have too many things
going on where reality like
there's tons going on
but I didn't miss it
and that's not a knock against Drew or
any of the people or whatever like maybe
it just ran its course so maybe I bring
it back in a month but if you take a
little separation from it and then you
realize that I don't actually miss that
thing then you should cut it out from
your life when I went to um the first
time with the Tony Robbins event
he I know it's the first time the second
time that when he actually invited me to
come in be his guest
uh they do this fire walk at the end
where you walk on fire and yeah
and I was gonna go because that was
Tony's guest I was going to be the first
one on the fire and he was going to
personally be the guy like yelling at
you to come across the fire not his team
like Tony was gonna personally Take Me
Out across the coast and I left I didn't
go do it not a knock against Tony but
what's the point of doing the firewalk
the firewalk is to get you to realize
you can do difficult things and so what
I did was instead was I went back to my
hotel and I I stopped doing four things
that I was doing that involved other
people commitments to other people that
I was doing that I felt bad for them
I felt like I owed them something I felt
like I was doing I didn't want to
disappoint them and so I stayed in
things that I shouldn't have stayed in
and like now is the time to grow and so
I did the that was the real fire walk
for me was stopping those things
so if you feel overwhelmed by things
um because there's too many things going
on then it's then it's cutting down some
of those things
recognizing what's the priority in your
life
so if it's overwhelmed on the how then
then then stop thinking about it and
just start doing because the house is
going to change million times if it's
the overwhelmed because you have too
many things going on then then it's
cutting down some of the things that you
have going on so you can focus on
building the life that you want to build
and it doesn't mean that like this is
where good is the enemy of great the
things that you if it was if it sucked
you would you would cut it
right like if you went to your women's
group and everybody just yelled at you
the whole time you would leave because
like I don't want to be yelled at all
the time the problem is most of the
things that we're doing they're just
good it's good yeah and the good is
preventing us from doing great things
and so you might have to look at the
calendar and I still do this like I do
this all the time looking at my calendar
and saying do I want to keep doing this
should I keep doing Instagram lives
should I keep meeting with the people in
my team should I keep like it's a
constant evaluation and you have to be
willing to let go of the good to go for
the great you know it's amazing what you
are saying because you are basically
giving a road map of all the things you
know someone and not only me but anyone
who's undertaking a new a new facing
life all the things that uh you know it
can be done to clarify and to find and
to find a
a clear way to go where you want to go
without feeling
born
and without feeling that you are been
tearing into pieces trying to get your
goal of achieving your dreams and yeah
it's it's kind of like you know
sometimes having that clarity
needs to come from someone else
many many times you kind of know some of
those things but it's good to have
someone telling you having that person
that boy is that mentor and sometimes we
don't look for that we try to do
everything by ourselves as as you were
saying and we start feeling drawn and
and it's it's yeah it's it's a little
bit of what happens to me and what I've
realized happens to many people that
it's going through changes in life uh
undergoing through their personal
Journeys and emotions is something else
that you know all the different emotions
that you experience when you're going
through changes how do you deal with
that I think
it's first off recognizing what is the
emotion where you feel safe
because a lot of times that emotion is
the thing that's actually holding you
back you have to get into the mo the
emotion it makes you feel uncomfortable
so why did I stay in those things for so
long well because it made me feel safe
you know because that's where home was
because I'd rather
be stuck and not grow then potentially
disappoint people
I'd rather stay in these groups and stay
with these commitments that I made
because I don't want to disappoint them
and it's good and it's emotionally hard
to get out of those and move to
something else that I want to do
so it's recognizing what is the emotion
that's keeping you stuck and safe and
how is it actually like it's beating you
because I don't want to disappoint
people that's the same thing for me I
don't want to disappoint people
um
so it's just shining the light on that
because that's the default my default
mode would be to try to serve and help
people and not disappoint them and that
may actually be holding me back from
doing something much bigger
when you get that light kind of shine on
it whether it's somebody else or whether
it's you
then it's just asking hey is there a way
like if you think about you mentioned
four different groups I think that
you're part of cool like let's say one
of those groups isn't really a great fit
for you anymore maybe it was maybe
you've grown and you learned from it
maybe you're maybe it was never like a
perfect group but now you feel kind of
committed to it is there a way that you
could leave the group
without making everybody feel terrible
and if you pose a question that way
there always is always an answer you
know like is there a way you can leave a
client or leave a relationship or leave
a group or leave a responsibility
without it being terrible
like how can I leave this in as good a
situation as possible if you just take
the time this is what I have to do if I
just take the time to think about it
I can come up with an answer it's like
oh it's actually not that hard to leave
this group and still have them be in a
good spot where they're not hating you
but it's the willingness to ask that
question and
getting through it like it's the it's
the comfort of staying in the group and
feeling like you know you you owe them
something then it's the fear of oh my
gosh if I leave the group they're gonna
hate me
then it's the excitement of okay but if
I free up that time I can go and do
something much bigger and have a bigger
impact right and then it's the Comfort
back to okay I can't actually leave this
group in a way that doesn't
destroy everything for all the people
who are in the group yeah so it's this
range of emotion that we go through but
most of it is the is the fear and the
uncertainty and it almost never ends up
being as bad as you thought it was going
to be because you're not going to leave
the group and say you know what guys
like I hate you and uh it's not working
and you suck and I'm out rather you're
not going to do that
you're gonna find a way to to leave
gracefully and and hopefully give them a
better path forward but we we all have
to like the next level of growth if you
want to go and do amazing things
you need to have time on your calendar
to be able to go off and do it which
means you may have to let go of some
relationships like the friends that you
were with in kindergarten may not be the
same people who are good friends for you
right now maybe you're stuck in a
relationship that's no longer the best
relationship for you maybe you hire
people on your team who aren't good fits
for where you want to grow anymore and
we're okay for where they're at the
number of entrepreneurs they've had to
meet is coaching a guy in San Diego who
who built this business has got a
million dollar company hired five people
they're all his friends and he realized
that like they're not the people that
take him to 10 million
and so he hired his friends and that now
it's not a good fit anymore so he's got
to move on from them and it's hard to
fire your friend yeah
but we have to move on from some of the
relationships and some of the
commitments that we've made
in order to get to the next level
and yes that's that's the thing like
because I guess that everyone who
starts any type of change or journey is
because he feels it's better it's it's
good enough to look for something better
in their lives
so
making that difficult decision you know
finding the way to to manage the fear
and the anxiety and all you know to make
the difficult decision and realize that
doing it it will allow you to be a
better version of yourself you know that
that is
I guess you know what I'm extracting
from you like you know give yourself
that that possibility to to believe that
you can be that you can be it's just a
matter of doing these these things that
you are doing this process analyzing
what is the real you know what are the
reals the real things that I need to be
involved at what are the renunciations
that I have to do even though they are
difficult and uh and you know continue
into that
original idea and original plan original
big dream that you know that that we
have like everyone has right and listen
Community matters too a lot in all of
this like being around people who are
doing a thing or supportive of you when
doing a thing matters you know you look
at what you do if you for somebody to
immigrate to a new country
that's a lot of that's a hard decision
that's not just like oh yeah let's move
to Canada like it's for most people
you're leaving your home you're leaving
your family you're leaving your
community you're leaving you have to
learn a whole new language being a whole
new country and understand all the new
laws and there's that's a that's a tough
choice for a lot of people doing that is
harder than almost anything else you
know leaving everything behind and going
to a new country
what makes it easier
is being around people who've also
immigrated to that country
you know it's like if you move to a new
country and you're all by yourself
you're all alone you have no friends
nobody speaks your language nobody
understands your culture you're just
sitting in your basement of your new
rental home or apartment all day long
you're like that's a that's a really
dangerous Narrow Path what helps is
people meeting people like Kanye you
know meeting people who are who are in
the community make meeting people who've
also moved to a new country you know
people supporting you on the new Journey
so it's about being around the people
because if you're around your family and
the people you know your old friends or
where you came from what are they going
to say stay here don't go there stay
here this is where everything is at but
you know you want to go there so the
people who were with you back there they
want you to stay with them but you need
people for where you're going
and being around those people more will
will help give you the courage and the
motivation and the inspiration as well
as the tactics and the tools and the
introductions but the feeling that
you're not alone because when you leave
a place is where I said like we're all
immigrants even if you were born in the
country you're at because to leave a
place
where you feel like you belong and now
you're going to a new place where you
don't belong
is really scary and that's a main reason
why a lot of people never make that
Journey because they don't want to do it
alone so they'd rather stay safe and
comfortable and in the community where
they belong then go off and try to find
something new so a lot of people stay in
a broken relationship because they're
afraid that they won't find anybody else
and so rather be with somebody who is
abusive or neglectful then be with
nobody right we feel like we can't get
to the next spot because
we're stuck where we are and so just
being just the importance of community
like whatever you're trying to do don't
do it alone
find people even if it doesn't mean that
the person you find is going to be your
best friend for life
but in joining communities in being a
part of the thing with that where you're
going you will find your tribe and
looking back you know in five years or
ten years later be like I can't believe
that's who I used to be I'm so glad I
continued on the journey yeah yeah and
something that you you used to say you
say a lot and I love it because it has
helped me so much is when you are in
doubt when you have you're not sure
about what to decide
um big decisions with your with your
heart small decisions with your head
yes and uh and that has been so like
such a big
um guide for me uh since years ago like
when I started listening about you and
uh when you know when I need to make
those kind of decisions I use that that
principle big decisions with your heart
and small decisions with your head uh
because in the end
um there's a biggest knowledge right
that goes beyond the intellect and
that's definitely something that we can
use so it's something that I I try to to
lean on and Community definitely it's uh
it's something that we all we all can
use and as immigrants we definitely need
a strong Community strong Community as a
person as individuals to like me being
part of movement makers helps me so much
in many sense and uh you know being
around you having this opportunity
talking to you that's definitely and you
know extracting those little things or
big things and big thoughts that may
help me definitely are helping me and
will help many other people that you
know that can listen to this I've been
checking all the hearts and all the
comments and I'm just so grateful that
you know that you share all this with us
with me and yeah thank you so much an
easy way to look at is you know if
you're feeling overwhelmed by the amount
of work that you're doing you look at
the calendar and just look at the day
ahead or look at the week ahead and what
in your calendar
gets you excited and what in your
calendar makes you like oh my God
like that's a heart decision right it
may make super logical sense for you to
do that thing but if it if it sinks your
energy then it's not worth doing long
term doesn't mean you quit it right now
but you know you have to get out of that
thing longer term when I look at my
calendar I see Tanya Gonzalez in the
house like let's go it's gonna be fun
you know if I look at like oh Tanya no
you know then and then I should be doing
ubering I should be doing something
completely different right I look at it
I'm excited so I should keep I should
keep doing it right and so if you look
at your calendar we tend to We tend to
prioritize just the things that make
sense but if you feel like you're at the
end of every day and you're super
drained and you have no energy and and
you need like a huge break to deal with
everything that you just went through
today well maybe you're doing the wrong
stuff you know like and and doing the
right things may not make sense yet but
having time on your calendar to at least
cut out some of the things that are
making you feel low energy and replacing
them with things that you can get
excited by even if they don't work out
short term that's the path to creating
the new life that you want to create so
don't make a list of pros and cons like
should I do this or not
pros and cons because you're trying to
make a big decision with your head it's
like no which one which one do you love
more like which one is more exciting for
you to go off and try because if you do
the work that makes you feel excited and
gives you energy like I have more energy
leaving you than coming into you like
you are you gave me energy you didn't
take away my energy and hopefully the
same for you you know hopefully you're
leaving so this is like two plus two
equals eight thousand because you're
you're combining things and we're we're
both leaving I'm assuming more energetic
than than when we came in right so it's
like a sign that you're doing the right
thing and if you're leaving if you're
leaving tasks feeling depleted you
should not be doing that long term again
it doesn't mean you quit that thing
right now doesn't mean you quit the
relationship or the job or the
partnership or whatever like in the
moment maybe you do but at least having
a plan to get out there because you
don't want to explain the next five ten
years of your life doing that thing that
you hate
and I guess that also helps you with
guilt like not building feeling guilty
about making those hard decisions like
you know having in front of you the
possibility of growth like yes I'm
cutting all these but in the future I
will have all these other
chances open to me because I'm making
this difficult decision at this moment
which you know I think that for many
people it's something like that you feel
guilty about making those hard decisions
because you will affect someone else and
it's hard to make that decision it goes
you know beyond you it's not only you're
not even thinking on you but in you what
you're saying like in you giving
yourself that chance to grow sooner or
later you will benefit many more
yeah if you want to reduce the guilt of
dropping something you do two things you
either
raise how much excitement you have for
what's coming so you raise the level of
well if I free up this time I can go
build this and I can help that and then
I can have this impact because I have
this extra time so we're raising the
excitement for the future that you've
got and then also how do you lower the
risk of something bad happening so you
have you got two things to pull like I'm
going to get more excited about the life
that I'm going to build and I'm going to
reduce the impact of me leaving so again
you're not just going to lead the group
and say that's it I'm out you guys suck
have fun like how do you leave we just
never asked the question like how do I
leave this group or leave this person in
a way that reduces the downside as much
as possible it may not be zero like if
we're gonna get rid of a client we try
to pass them on to somebody else where
it might be a better fit not just hey
you suck you're out like try to give
them a better path out yeah
um so both of those get excited about
the future and lower the downside as
much as possible and it gives you the
freedom to go in and build and make and
create because
where most people get stuck is just the
complacency of staying where you are
because it's comfortable and it's safe
and it's what you know as opposed to
getting out into the unknown but that's
where all of the magic happens like the
magic doesn't happen by you staying who
you are oh yeah magic happens by you
changing and growing different that's
not an option because yeah it may be
comfortable I always think that Comfort
is that song that it's warm and nice but
it will burn at the end it will take the
best of you at the end so that's not an
option never never you know just we need
to make that that that leap of faith I I
have I've always wondered something have
you ever thought like in your past you
know when you were very young and when
you were dealing with all the things
that you've dealt until you've shared
with us right about all the you know the
the doves about you uh you being able to
do all what you're doing
have you ever or did you ever thought
that you will find greatness
did you ever felt that inside you that
you know I have to keep going because I
feel that there's something so big
inside of me that I need to give myself
the chance to keep going because I'm
gonna be great
um only to the extent that I think
everybody has that okay you know and
maybe that's because my mom was my hero
or I'm Canadian or whatever you know
smallest yeah maybe that's like just
baked into us but
um yes and I think that
I think that everybody has the Michael
Jordan level genius or something like
everybody is great at something you're
the best in the world is something and
we've gotta we've got to find out what
that thing is and you got to dedicate
the time to to then practice in it and
actually getting really great at it's
like believing that you even can be
great and then believe in yourself
enough to chase down that dream
um I think really really matters so uh
yes I believe I'm great that I believe
you're great I believe everybody
watching here is great at something and
then the tricky part is this is why
everybody is an immigrant like it's not
what you were born into you know like
you what you're great at is not what
your parents did for living it's not
what you went to school to learn it's
not what any of your friends are doing
it's something completely different
and it takes a lot of courage to go off
and leave the comfort of your home to
then go and like you stay in in your
little village or you go and build a
castle you know most people just stay in
their little village where like you
everybody can have their own castle it's
like you can but it takes a lot of
courage to walk that path and yeah you
always say something else that I love I
like a lot is it's a muscle you know
being being uh being brave it's a muscle
that we can develop and making those
difficult decisions it's something that
you we can work on doing more and more
and it's going to be more and you know
easier every time and yeah 100 like I
remember when when you joined uh our
insiders group so we have for anybody
who buys any of my books we have a
Facebook group that we meet
um and we have events kind of once a
week for free if you got the book uh and
Tanya joined one of the first sessions
but didn't say anything the first time
to do and just kind of sat there and
watched and then and then I think the
second time or the third time you're
like a little question and now here you
are you're going live it's like imagine
look at all the content you've made all
the live streams you've done all the
people you've helped all the videos that
you like Tanya from I don't know how
long ago that was a year and a bit ago
maybe I may around may may last year
like look at even even just in so that's
what a year and a half or a year and a
couple months like how much growth
you've had
I made this this year made this year no
this is this year it was last year yeah
no I just had surgery yeah in April 202
I had surgery and after that I I became
a movement maker
in April
wow okay so if that's insane so even
just look at that like look at how much
you've grown since April May
if you showed yourself this like if if
we went back to February Tanya and said
hey look at what you did in October
that's not me that's not happening
there's no way there's no way and that's
only a few months later yeah now imagine
what you can do in a year two years or
five years or ten years it's crazy
you're literally an impossibility like
Tanya from March would think that Tanya
from October is impossible because I can
never do that it's impossible and yet
you've already done it in a really tight
window
it's it's part of being the right in the
right community that has made such a big
difference for me like I I remember you
saying I'm an introvert I'm an introvert
and I'm you know I've been able to
evolve myself to do all these things
that are not likely for a person who's
an introvert and I'm a shy person so I
said okay you know this person can do it
and it's not comparing myself to anyone
but you know it is is possible to give
that switch to your to your personality
to character we are not Define what by
what we are at this moment like we are
really not I really believe that and
I've made many changes in my life and
this last phase in my life you know
doing these big
um opening myself to do all these things
like it has given me some so much
fulfillment and a sense of
um a sense of confidence and gratitude
and uh it's it's really like yes I feel
myself as an example that you can change
and I'm committed to live that shy girl
like you know at the side I know that
she exists I know that she is there but
I don't want her to Define me and I know
that there's more people everyone can do
it it's just you know surrounding with
the right people and finding those those
possibilities to to Really find your
potential so I'm very grateful that I
found you your community because it has
made a big difference in my life yeah
join movement makers during our
challenge right the first filter serve
challenge
wow I thought it was at least a year
no but it's only been like four or five
months
uh yes I think so yeah it's was that
around April April this year right May
June July August September and it's what
October 3rd yeah so we're into our sixth
that's crazy yeah and yeah I've
experienced so many changes like in my
life I would have thought that I would
be doing this because I was so private
that I not even my Facebook was to I
wasn't active not even in Facebook so
even learning all these has been such a
big experience so having the right
motivation makes all the difference in a
p on someone's life regular life because
I'm you know
quiet person like you know I just like
little things like I like dance outside
like my work I like working with
immigrants I like those kind of things
but you know learning about all these
possibilities gave me such a different
insight about what can I do and how can
I help and why should I help
and why should I not keep everything to
myself but sometimes I feel overwhelmed
and sometimes I feel like I question
myself you know should I go back to a
more quiet life should I you know just
take it a little bit easier but
something inside me tells me no
well listen it's never going back like
if you make a if you make a shift or a
change it's never going back it's just
going somewhere else yeah you know it's
like the the caterpillar becomes the
butterfly the butterfly never goes back
to becoming a caterpillar
um but the butterfly also doesn't stay
on the same tree forever yeah the
butterfly flies away and goes other
places so it's never going back like you
never want to be the Kanye who you used
to be there's nothing wrong with her she
helped you get to where you are now but
we never go back you're just lines
somewhere else but but the butterflies
wants to fly you know the butterfly
doesn't stay stuck the caterpillar's
stuck you know the caterpillar's stuck
on the tree
becomes a butterfly and the butterfly
flies away so
um
anyway I'm just still stuck on the
you've only been with us for five months
like I'm so excited to see what you're
doing the next five years this is crazy
Tanya let's go
you know I I see like all the time I
have so many you know thoughts and plans
and ideas and now that I've done a
little bit I believe
using your you know your core I believe
that I can do much more and uh not only
you know that will be in benefit of
myself but also in benefit of everyone
that I can touch uh something I you
always said is uh not always is willing
to hear something from uh
a specific person but it's open to hear
it from someone else
and you know I really want to tap into
that because I may be able to you know
to to give a little bit of Hope
inspiration uh a loving push for so many
people who is waiting on the dog
you know on the port not deciding to
Embark in their Journeys so I hope I can
give them that little bit of tools to
make their Journey easy because it is
possible it is possible for regular
people to make
things that you know are a little bit
extraordinary yeah and listen you
started that same I may be able to you
definitely will and you already are
you know like you already are you you
already are doing it we we had um we had
our clubhouse session the other day on
the on the weekend to kind of celebrate
people who finished the challenge and a
woman joined and
she was talking about how she was so
kind of introverted and shy and you know
couldn't speak and would never get
making videos and now she's like how do
I help inspire people I think but you
were like you're here you're already
doing it you already are you're you've
already helped tons of people it may not
be where you end up right like you may
think oh it's nothing
compared to what other people are doing
but you've already had an impact
on people's lives and it's only going to
scale and get bigger and grow more
so it's it's just perspective a lot of
times we're so worried about where we're
going that we haven't taken the time to
look back and say oh I was over there
that's crazy
which helps with the overwhelm as well
it helps with the it helps with the
Imposter syndrome it helps with the I'm
not good enough you think well I'm not
Oprah or I'm not whoever you know
whoever you hear is I'm not I'm not that
big yet
you know when do I start sharing but
like you've already you've already had
an impact you're already doing it
so on the days when you feel
uh this is what I do a lot with the
people on my team and the entrepreneurs
I've invested into most of the work is
making them see how awesome they are
um there are some days you know Alex
comes in uh and he says like he's the
greatest instructor in the world then
I'll I'll knock him down he's like dude
you suck like you're just getting
started but on most of the days is
coming in with the I'm not good enough
energy he's like look how far you've
come like Alex from five years ago who
walked in and was like the worst dancer
in his class look at what you've become
and so we often forget the perspective
to see the journey that we've climbed
and every time you take that step you
can go help somebody else's stuck at
Step Zero yeah and that you know that
teaching of you to treat ourselves with
uh Grace
you know to to to be kind to ourselves
it's uh so like so so important because
otherwise it's falling twice not only
you you know you you failed at doing
something but you come and you treat
yourself bad that's falling twice so
yeah it's it's it's very nice that that
you're saying you know treat yourself
this is where like a great Community a
great mentor can help because when
you're there's no
there's no one answer like sometimes you
need to be lifted up when you feel
really low you need to be lifted up and
when you feel on top of the world that
you feel you know too egomaniac you need
to be brought back down
you know it's like you need to you're
just getting started get to work go you
think you you think you awesome you're
awesome you suck let's go but most of
the time it's the opposite where the
needs like dude you're amazing you know
you've done so much and so having
um
having the support of people and mentors
to kind of guide in and hug you when you
need it and push you where you need it I
think it's really valuable and you're
doing that for other people too
thank you thank you so much
okay well tell me I mean you got a
YouTube campaign or video like give me
the details and how can I help
okay
so uh first of all I have to tell you I
did apply the two percent rule that you
have been uh able to help me understand
back in the spring I started to write my
book truth and dare daring to live your
truth in a fake world and in that book I
started to write my stories just very
heart compelled Stories the reason why I
learned certain principles and they're
they're very real very honest stories
one of those stories I felt very
compelled to create a video and while I
was excited I got out and I got the I I
went out there found my videographer
started put it together it was a magical
experience and once we started to get
into it I recognized that the story that
I was sharing was all about some sexual
trauma that I had experienced as a as a
younger teenager and moving past that
and into allowing myself to unpeel the
layers of trauma so that the real me
could show up in in this heart-centered
able to receive love able to give love
able to show up better greater uh with
with a greater capacity and the video is
beautiful it's got actors actresses over
a hundred people in the local community
that came out the videographers did an
amazing job we shot this very compelling
beautiful story and on 9 11 very
deliberately we launched the campaign so
we're moving past me too and into time
to heal that's the movement that's the
campaign and my desire is to evoke that
that my my honest full like this is a
transparent story I don't I don't hide
anything I show everything and I put it
out there my heart is out there so that
I can help women to understand that
perhaps their trauma is impeding them
from living in their highest best is
masking them and I like to say the light
of the soul is hard and challenging to
see when it's shadowed by the trauma of
yesterday so that is really what this
movement is Hey sisters it's now time to
rise it's not now time to heal the time
is now
so that's it we did it on 911 because
the trauma of our country brought us
together as Americans and so 911 was
also a start of let's unite together
those of you that are part of this me
too but now let's lift each other and
help each other become the best versions
of ourselves by lending support by
loving each other by telling each of
your other different ways that we were
able to heal and grow so here we are 9
11. the video did well
um it but here's the thing
um I also recognize in me too that a gal
by the name of Tarara Burke actually
launched that movement back in 2007 and
then it really didn't become a huge
movement until 2017 when Alyssa Milano
came out and said hey make sure that
everybody hashtags me too so that's when
it really became big well I'm not Alyssa
mulatto I'm not in the public eye like
that so where does a girl like me really
start to take off and what would you
encourage me to do to help gather those
that need this in their lives so that's
why I'm coming to you is to to get that
uh more of a a very
a deliberate actionable plan we did the
creation now it's time to put it into to
a plan
all right this is great there's so much
in here this is amazing lots to work
with
um first off like congrats on doing it
congrats on writing the book and sharing
your soul and like especially when
you're talking about trauma that's so
hard to
get it out there it's like you feel
naked sharing this and you're going to
judge me and yeah so that takes a
tremendous amount of courage and your
willingness to be seen and share makes
other people who've been through it feel
less alone like if one person looks at
that and say oh I'm not
like I'm not alone other people have
gone through this no you know you give
hope like this is how you give Hope by
sharing your story uh because if you're
silent it perpetuates the silence
clay yes and when we bring it out into
the light
hunger exist anymore
this is a story I never thought I would
share like this is my inner circle story
Evan this is not a story I was going to
give to the world but I felt like if my
heart said if you will do this then
you're courageous and brave it will
impact and help someone else so yes
thank you well and I love that you went
from like the idea to the book and then
one of the stories that becomes a video
it's like it's great this these are all
you know the seeds that who knows what
it's gonna
what Forest will be created from that
little you know sapling that you planted
on 9 11.
um okay couple things in here the first
is recognizing that this is a movement
and this is an ongoing this is a mission
this is not just like how do we promote
this for the next week this is forever
this is you know like let's get eyes on
this thing and it's it's this is what
happens a lot of times when people are
launching books like oh I'm just gonna
it's out cool let's try to hit a list
and then that's it as opposed to no
there's a movement that I'm trying to
build and when you talk about me too
taking a decade or whatever it was for
it to actually start taking taking shape
and getting attention that's right the
work and it wasn't a failure in the
first 10 years could have gone faster
yes but there's the work behind the
scenes in the trenches planting you know
watering nurturing that seed to become
something much bigger like two things
one for the video right now that's ready
to come out I would be
linking it everywhere that you've got
it's in the bio of your IG it's the
trailer on your YouTube page it's in the
newsletter that you put out on your
email list it's uh in the PS of every
email in your signature and your email
like PS check out the story on whatever
um okay it's like any communication
that's being sent out it's there for
people to go and potentially check out
so okay
um you know the PS online is Joe my
disco so any email that I send off it's
like join the Discord but yours could be
PS like I don't know how many emails you
send out a day you know maybe it's 10
maybe it's 20 maybe it's 200 but
everybody who it's just automatically
kind of baked in their PS here it is so
anywhere where you're creating any kind
of content website social email videos
bio links the video is there
that's an easy starting point uh the
second thing is because it's a YouTube
video I would look at how well the video
did retention wise and see if there
might be edits or tweaks or hacks like
is there a cut down version are there
moments when you lose their retention
because if people are dropping off if we
cut that part out the video has a better
chance to succeed and win
um the good news is Evan is six minutes
and 53 seconds and the attention is
there let's go the whole thing so yeah
cool but thank you I'm going to continue
now that could have been because the
first initial push were people in My
Tribe so we'll keep looking at that sure
and and then you can split test the
thumbnail and what's our title and what
we're going to call it no like if you're
thinking more long term and reaching out
right even just on this video let alone
like we'll move to the whole movement
afterwards but just for the video
what's the main like so me too obviously
everybody knows
it's time to heal or like what's the
what's the main
phrase
hashtag time number two heal that's it
yeah time to heal perfect
any uh groups any uh coaches any
contents being put out like any any uh I
don't know how like if somebody has this
trauma where are they going who are they
reaching out to what groups are they
joining whether they're paid or free or
meetups or whatever it is to have that
video potentially be a part of the
healing process for them
so if there's uh anywhere down from like
a shelter that people might be going to
or religious organizations or groups or
like where do people go to connect and
start to share their story and then you
connecting with the connectors
and putting this video on their
attention that maybe your video is the
thing that helps explain something in a
way that they couldn't explain or just
another way to be able to see it so you
know if I look at I don't know what the
I don't know enough about like the
trauma of sexual trauma world to know
like where people go
and it may not be as organized as
something like Alcoholics Anonymous but
if we use AAA just as an example imagine
if your video was talking about healing
from that as opposed to sexual trauma
and then imagine if your videos was
played on day one of every AAA meeting
so it's baked into the process right so
who are the like if I wanted to do that
who who do I have to talk to inside of
AAA is it the whoever's like the CEO of
AA is it on an individual chapter level
do they have a newsletter that they're
all talking to each other like how does
the curriculum get organized that's not
an overnight thing right but it's a
movement you know and it's valuable and
the story that you told in the video in
a year and two years and five years is
still valuable it's still relevant it's
not just a 2022 September 11th thing so
like the timing of the launch was very
cool and now it's in a year it still
just as helpful and relevant
so where are these women going right now
and how can you be a part of that
healing journey to assist the assisters
so a lot of teachers use my videos in
their classrooms
and I got a the number of teachers have
written to me to say like thank you for
not putting swearing in your videos
because I play it to my grade eight
classrooms as part of like homeroom
every day or something and that was
never actually my intention we just
moved to swear words because I don't
swear it's just my own thing
um but what a great like byproduct right
so if I wanted to get into like now it's
just a bunch of teachers who are doing
it but if I wanted to be in the
education system now it's like okay how
do I get more teachers to play my videos
how do I who do I have to talk to was it
a teacher level or superintendent level
or
Etc right and it might be different for
different states and different you know
counties so that becomes the work and
maybe that's you maybe that's your tribe
maybe that's your assistant it's like
how do we
who are the people who are who are the
helpers and how do we help the helpers
so you're not just helping the end the
actual
uh survivors but you're helping the
helpers
so we're making a list of like a
thousand helpers Across America love
that who are those people and then how
can I help you how can I assist you and
the first lead-in is with the video this
is an easy this is a story they're going
to heal through it it's not the only
thing you have your own methodology cool
but this might add to somebody's healing
right
um right
what that then does is help you build a
much bigger movement on top of just the
video where imagine that you had your
list of a thousand helpers and you're in
contact with them and they know who you
are and you're all working towards the
same thing of now it's time to heal
maybe not like exactly how you see it
but they're they're doing their own
version of it too
when you want to launch the next thing
your book your next book your Mastermind
your own training centers Across America
or your Healing Centers across like now
you have people who can support you and
join you and you've been working with
and training with and so there's like
the immediate strategy just around how
do I get this video out but there's the
ongoing of how do I build a network
Across America of not just a survivors
but the helpers because that leads to so
many things for the rest of your life
for the rest of the movement that you're
you're trying to build and create so
that becomes a call to action like you
your followers your audience your
newsletter like let's work on a list
let's get a thousand people who are
helping
who are helping the survivors so we want
to help the helpers and then you start
reaching out and it could be Instagram
Twitter you know email phone calls and
to to not do it alone because I can feel
over like how do I get a thousand people
across the American feel like it's gonna
it's gonna end up like that box behind
you that then it's just like something
to look at it's like it's not happening
uh
and and so the easiest way to do it is
you you put a time in your calendar that
Tuesday afternoons is movement Outreach
time and you're trying to figure out how
do I have like half the day or whatever
fits into your calendar but like this is
important for
for you for the women you're helping and
for the rest of your life like you're
going to be 90 years old still caring
about this
absolutely if anything even more like
like no this is so important that you
get this right so yeah so it's it's
amazing in the short term of this one
video but there's so many of these
videos and projects and courses and
Healing Centers and VR and all the stuff
that will come because unfortunately you
know when you're 90 people will still be
experiencing sexual trauma and will
still meet the heel you know yeah so
this is a Lifeline lifetime mission that
we're on
um so if you set you know side Tuesday
afternoons I'm going to spend four hours
every Tuesday doing this work and the
Outreach and it's you finding the names
it's it's dming people and messaging
people and asking for help even like you
did this right like you Kira mentioned
to me that you wanted to do this and so
here we are I'm talking about this right
here we are yeah so getting
like enlisting help
and it may be a no you know like I could
have said hey I don't have time right
now right it's probably not going to be
I hate you Wendy forget about it right
like you're probably not going to get
those kind of responses
um but for some people maybe it's just
the wrong time in the Sun not now but
it's not a personal rejection of you and
the mission of what you're doing but but
the important part is to not try to do
everything on your own and to build the
list of a thousand people on your own
and to do the Outreach all on your own
because it it's lonely you lose
motivation and it just feels
overwhelming that this is not possible
right um
so part of the work on a Tuesday
afternoon or whatever you set aside is
how do I enlist people to help me like
hey do you want to help me find 100
people do you set up people in different
states is the goal to have how many
states are there in the U.S 52. 50
what do they think too is Alaska not a
state yeah yeah I guess if you thought
Puerto Rico or you know those types of
things that maybe a couple that's right
you're kidding I'm Canadian so whatever
uh but like if you wanted to have a
captain for every state and now you're
recruiting 50 captains or whatever you
want to leaders or whatever language you
want to use but now they're responsible
for their state
right and so like hey you're you're a
New York champion and you're our Arizona
I need I need a
I need an Ohio Champion who's gonna be
my Ohio and like I'll do that I'll I'll
help Wendy and and then Tuesday
afternoons maybe you're meeting with all
your champions for half an hour to
brainstorm ideas and like here's what
I'm doing okay cool and that might what
somebody's doing in Ohio might Inspire
the person in New York to do some
Outreach and so the sharing and it
becomes something much bigger than
just one video which kind of started the
whole thing right right
but if you don't like schedule time and
you don't
ask people for help then it stays small
yes or it stays that like list of ideas
on the the wall behind right it's like
you know what there's so much good
that's here if it's like until we do
something about it nothing ends up
happening the other thing I would look
at is how much work you want to do
actually helping the survivors and how
can you do that and I don't know
survivors is the right word of what you
would want to call it I think that's
beautiful I mean survivors I like to
consider this movement is taking that
victimization of me too and and moving
it to Victor right now and and just
allowing themselves that is now an
experience that we had it's something
that has shaped
how we have you know how how we've shown
up in the world but now we have more
compassion now we have more empathy now
we can connect and especially once we
dismantle all of the trauma and the
trauma responses that we have based on
that trauma now we can really show up
now we can really shine our light and
absolutely I think Survivor is a great
uh word but I think Victor is it even
more empowering word right and and those
are exactly like we're putting into
pieces lots of different things like
groups where we can collectively share
ideas be that that soft place to land
for individuals because my first thing
my first encouragement is start
somewhere start anywhere it's it's kind
of like your two percent start somewhere
do it once we marinate we will talk
ourselves out of it every single time so
if our heart leads and we start that
movement and we take some action
wherever that is even if it's just
starting with the Facebook group we took
some action now we get ideas now our
heart is open now we start to see what
we can do in order to heal because the
world needs individuals that are in that
healing phase it invites I believe
healing women will heal a broken and
hurt world because it invites the men to
participate and then it also allows the
children to see what does happy look
like what does joyful look like what
does self-confident look like oh mom is
self-confident mom loves herself mom
shows up in this world and she doesn't
hide and she doesn't self betray and she
she shines her life so that's what I see
with this movement it really does have
the the capacity to be to impact
millions of lives because it starts with
the individual goes to the family goes
to the community right so absolutely I
think that it's important for us to have
resources for them to start where do you
start you know if you've not gone down
this road where do you start
so the strategies that we just talked
about will work the language and the
naming you can finesse and play with
right so like if we're having a a
champion or a captain of each state
maybe you don't like Captain or Champion
like I'm just trying I'm searching for
names but like having somebody in chat
or you can like it's a heroine or it's
like uh I don't know whatever like
whatever you may meditate on and you
pray on it and and like boom the word
antigen but that idea and it should be
empowering I'm using more generic terms
but it could be it could be like we're
all our own Joan of Arc and like you're
you're the Joan of like whatever it
could be like the strategy will work
we're just but language becomes an
important part of any movement so it's
shipping empowering position that I am
the blank for Ohio
um and Survivor cool if you want to call
it the victors that they may not
identify themselves as a Victor yet but
that's where they want to get to
um typically if you want to scale it
then the work becomes helping the
helpers
so the people who already have a
community so that you don't have to
build community one by one
they're already this here's this person
who's got a community of a thousand
women who've been through this trauma
like how do I get into that Circle
uh and if you're gonna help people
then if you're going to help the
survivors and it's going to be something
that has potential to scale
so like this
we're doing it as an Instagram I'm
helping you and hopefully
yes you are absolutely and it's
Instagram live that then maybe gets sent
into a YouTube video so that hopefully
other people get the value from it as
well so it's not just a one-on-one
right so it's a one-on-one but it's at
scale so if you're going to be helping
uh survivors then do you have your own
show where you're helping survivors do
you do an Instagram live once a day with
some Survivor and you you coach her or
you help her you just hug her or like
depending on where they're at you meet
people where they're at you take them as
far as they can go some people just
sharing their story and not being judged
and holding the space
is the beginning of healing without even
telling them anything about what to do
just listening and being an ear and not
judging them is
a great starting point for healing so do
you have some kind of show or some kind
of at scale whether it's Instagram or
Tick Tock or YouTube or newsletter where
you're shame people's stories or just
something where it's not
that's the one-on-one work because I
love the one on work it's my favorite
like this is awesome
and it doesn't scale and so if I want to
impact the world I need to be doing it
at scale and so same thing for you uh if
you want like how much one-on-one work
do you want to do
and is there a way to turn it into
something that other people can learn
from as well because when
Sharon from Nebraska comes on and shares
her story and you're talking to her and
you're helping her people watching will
see themselves and sharing and how
courageous she is and like maybe I don't
have to suffer alone too
and that's the goal like hopefully
people watching this
or maybe the replay on YouTube uh if
they have a movement that they're trying
to get out to the world they can use a
lot of the same strategy to talk about
even if trauma and sexual abuse is like
not the things you're trying to
to solve right right
um so like those two things is the help
the helpers and some kind of helping the
survivors at scale through content
um but then that just is rinse and
repeat and rinse repeat for the next
eight years of your life
beautiful
I could see it I think this is a great
great uh it's been amazing with what
you've been able to offer me today and I
think it's a great starting point for me
to I I can see the vision a lot bigger
than I did before and uh so I really
feel like this has been incredibly
helpful
I love it when to win win that's great
and like the best part is you're doing
it you know a lot of times we may feel
like
it's not enough because it like how many
people are struggling with this how many
women across America or around the world
have struggled with this it probably
even worse in other countries uh I mean
I don't know the stats but I wouldn't
every three females but I'm gonna tell
you I would say it's much higher than
that I would say it's two and three
I'm globally in some countries is
definitely way worse
I agree with that and I don't know like
how much you want to dive into that
world or not
um but like even just in America alone
or throw Canada in there too you know
it's uh it's it's a big deal and a lot
of times you can look at like it's not
enough like I wrote a book and I made a
video and it's not it's not enough it's
not hitting enough people and like who
am I to go and do this insane giant
thing
and it's just every day taking another
step and you know the if you look at me
too when she started it a decade before
Alyssa Milano like you'll have your own
Alyssa Milano moments
yeah with it too but only if you keep
every day Elaine another brick or or
plant another seed or watering that tree
a little bit more it's like in the
day-to-day work that is fulfilling in
itself yeah like helping the helper or
doing energy live with somebody who
like you help that one person it may not
feel like it's doing the big mission but
all those little
bricks that you you plant every day end
up you look back like oh my God I built
a house this is crazy
yeah that's beautiful I love this I
think this is super helpful and gives me
a very very specific way to approach my
next steps
honestly the biggest thing is the
calendar like now back to like dreaming
in the clouds and how we're going to
change the world and looking at like
making it tactical like yeah there has
to be
a couple hours at least every week that
you block off and you guard and you
defend and say like this is super
important to me and
90 of the time and that's there like I'm
gonna do it like there may be some cases
where something happens but for the most
part like you're showing up and doing it
and even if you don't know what you're
gonna do on that day like here's Tuesday
afternoon I'm gonna spend four hours
working on this Mission and I don't know
what to do next cool you you still work
on it you pray on it and you meditate on
it and you ask for guidance on it it's
like that's in your calendar and
something has to get done this week and
some weeks will be better you know and
more productive than others but like if
it's not in the calendar it doesn't get
done and remains it's like hope and
dream and it what often happens and I'm
not saying it's with you but often
happens is like you start and stops and
start and stops or it's like okay like
book massive progress yes out cool and
then nothing for a while oh video like
massive progress cool and and then
nothing for a while where the real gains
are made in like the everyday every week
the consistency that I said I was gonna
do it it's not as sexy it's not as maybe
fun as doing a new like video project
but if it's just this kind of quick hits
of projects it doesn't end up actually
having a huge impact that you're trying
to have where it's it's just showing up
every week even when you doubt yourself
you don't know what to do but it's in
the calendar and I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something to move it forward a little
bit nah it's beautiful and you're
exactly right I mean it is in that
long-term Vision the the long-term goal
and and helping it's that Snowball
Effect and so I think that I'm going to
be putting in my calendar some
non-negotiable time every single week
just like you mentioned uh and I love
the idea of having Instagram lives and
talking to survivors pictures about
their stories and really helping to
identify the blocks that are keeping
them from hanging on to it what what are
the trauma responses that they keep
finding themselves gravitating to and
how can we start to disband that so I
think it'd be a beautiful opportunity to
seal for others to see how this process
works and uh so I think those are some
fantastic starting points I even have a
couple of organizations already that do
work with trauma survivors and are
interested in showing my video video at
trainings at uh you know one of the
things that I first started with at my
first the first point that I was going
through my healing Journey was a
trauma-based retreat that allowed me to
learn how trauma stored house trauma is
released and that organization's huge
and they are they are looking at the
video right now we'll see what happens
great okay let me give you a bonus hack
just around that so okay so that's a
huge organization that you're going
after has any any organization actually
like done it yet
not yet we just did this on Sunday and
those emails and connections went out
yesterday so I'm just waiting for some
responses these are I I included people
that know these individuals personally
so that's not just me throwing out a an
email and hoping that it lands cool yeah
perfect you're already using your
Advocates and your Champions great okay
uh so what you do is once you get one
we want to use their name in future
outreaches
Okay so like what's the name of one or
like what's one that you'd love to have
or like maybe not like the giant huge
one but what's an example of like a name
of one that you would want to have um so
it used to be called the unique
Foundation uh was that unique makeup
company but now it's called the Supreme
organization or so Priya foundation so
that would be the one that I would just
celebrate uh okay in order to to get on
their radar and where are they based
here in Utah oh there you go and do they
do they help mostly like Utah women or
is it a it's across got it Supriya
Supreme Okay so
so that now becomes like Tuesday time or
whenever you know what whatever
afternoon time like Supriya is
has dedicated energy towards it you know
and like and even though you feel you've
done everything you prey on it and like
okay what else can I do to help get the
Supriya thing through who do I need to
talk to what do I need to manifest like
let's go get the Supreme thing has to
happen and being super clear with the
people
in your tribe and your audience to say I
want to get this at Supriya meetings
events Retreats trainings whatever
they're doing right okay because people
will then like when you're specific like
that people will find ways to try to
help you versus
I want to get this to the world cool but
like what's what do I do what do you how
can I help you you know yeah
um so once you get Supriya or you get
some other organization to do it even if
they're much smaller you then use their
name for all the future outreaches that
you're doing well like Supriya played it
in there as a part of their retreat
and you're mentioning the name and all
the future emails so that there's a
little bit more legitimacy and
credibility that like they're not the
first to do this and that there's this
is valuable and worth doing
uh and you the bigger names you get the
more you use the bigger names right like
if I'm trying to book somebody on my
interview show to come on
um you know like we're trying to we're
trying to get Oprah to come on and do
the interview right yes which is great
Oprah's doing like no interviews right
now like come on Oprah make it happen
let's go open whatever need to happen
you know my team would like name drop
the people who we've had on that she
might recognize you know that maybe you
were on her show where there's like
Deepak Chopra and Anthony Robbins and
Matthew McConaughey and you know those
kind of people uh now because we've had
them on and I can use them so you're
using those names and the bigger names
you get like if I get Oprah on then I'm
going to use Oprah's name in my future
emails and maybe drop somebody else
right so you build up
the second thing inside of that is if
you get whoever Supriya
you look at who's following them on
social
look who follows them on Instagram look
at who follows them on Tick Tock look at
who follows them on Facebook look who
follows them on Twitter
who's following them and they'll be like
a supreme will probably have a lot of
people following them I don't know how
big if their Global organization they
probably have significant following
maybe not Millions but I don't know but
who are the helpers who are following
them not the individuals
cap and a new Outreach to them and
there'd be a whole bunch of
organizations who you've never heard of
who may not be in Utah or they like
they're smaller or or maybe even bigger
you just never heard of them and when
you Outreach to them you say well
Supreme is using our video in their
training
now they're much more likely to listen
to you because you already know that
they care about Supriya because they're
following Supriya
beautiful so if you if you wrote to me
to say Supreme is used in my training
how about we show your video like I
don't know who Supreme is so it means
nothing
yeah but if they're already following
Supriya then you already know that they
know Supriya and they care about them
otherwise they probably wouldn't be
following them and so that can that can
one be a great way to build the list of
of helpers to do Outreach to and also
really dramatically increase your
chances of getting a yes from them and
it again doesn't have to be Supriya
level like maybe there's just some local
Utah Church who has a women's support
group
that has 40 people show up every week
and that's the first like it doesn't
have to be superior level Global
organization it's this local church
group and they have 400 followers on
Instagram
and you get in and your videos being
played at the next Church
session that they're going to be doing
and whoever is leading it says wow
Wendy's video was amazing thank you so
much
then the 400 people who are following
them on Instagram are all great
potential outreaches to you especially
if they're not just the the survivors
but they're the the helpers they're
organizations
and you start to build this connection
of all these people you can reach out to
and then you use the the church group
in the name in the in the in the message
out to them say Hey will this church
group just used the video I'd love to
show it to you as well and it means
something to them because they're
following them on Instagram
wow
that's amazing no wonder you have three
and a half million followers your bonus
hacks bonus hacks I love it cool well
thank you Wendy for people who want to
find the video or learn more about you
we're like where are they going
okay so on Instagram it's wendy.bunnel
uh two ends two L's N is a Nancy YouTube
Wendy bundle uh Facebook Wendy Bunnell
all the things illuminate your essence
and also wendybundle.com is my website
so you can find me anywhere by my name I
love it and we love you thank you Wendy
okay we'll see you soon
take care to see me coach another
entrepreneur one on one check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there it's not that we hate people
it's that we hate shallow conversations
yeah we want something that's deep and
meaningful I forgot how I was gonna open
up my speech serving others is hardwired
into US it makes you feel good how do
you find your purpose